[Musique]
ici nous produisons le meilleur tabac du
monde
el Pasito la viij
señor BAA se Baila all se Baila as por
la M se BAA se Baila all se Baila as por
la
[Musique]
madrug el Pasito
la la palabra tabaco
les mots Tabacco
pourba qui s'utilise beaucoup dans
l'argot du monde du cigare proviennent
des indigènes que colon a rencontré en
débarquant à
[Musique]
Cuba Tabacco qui veut dire cigare en
cubain est le nom originel qu'employent
les indiens pour désigner leurs cigares
et non le plan de
tabac le cigare a ensuite été très
souvent appelé pourau dans beaucoup de
régions d'Europe en référence à son
origine P
av capitale de la plus grande des îles
Caraïb La Havane est a cigar ce que
Venise est à la passion
amoureuse ici au pied de cette
cathédrale dessinée par la conquête
espagnole dans ces rues où les chansons
ont toutes les couleurs de peau quelques
feuilles de tabac roulé ensemble ont
donné naissance à une passion et un art
le Havane d'avenue en ruelle la ville
raisonne des noms des premières grandes
manufactures qui firent du cigare un
produit parfait et de grand luxe encore
bien vivante comme Partagas questestaré
ou sombrant dans l'oubli et la ruine
comme Roméo et Julietta leden oyo de
monteray la légitimidade nombre de ces
fabriques ont laissé leur nom aux
grandes marques internationales de
havane d'aujourd'hui les autres les
petites les disparu seuls quelques
images qui ornaient les boîtes de leur
production témoignent de leur passage
dans l'histoire du
[Musique]
pourau
une histoire qui a commencé il y a 5
siècles la première rencontre de l'homme
européen avec le cigare a eu lieu entre
le 2 et le 5 décembre
1492 sur les côte de l'ancienne province
d'Oriente en un point que l'on situe sur
une frangeche de 50 km
environ à peine débarqué à Cuba Rodrigo
de RZ compagnon de Colon parti explorer
l'intérieur des terres rencontra l'un de
ses indiens taainos habitant de l'île
tenant à la main une herbe en feu dont
il aspirait la fumée c'est ce cigare
originel véritable barreau de chaise de
la taille d'un mousquet auquel les
Indiens attribuaient des vertus magiques
et que les conquistadors allaient
adopter à son retour en Espagne Rodrigo
de Res rapporta quelques-uns de ses
mousquets comme on appelait alors les
énormes cigares des Indiens un
après-midi qu'il était assis dans la
cour de sa maison il en sortit l'alluma
et commença à le fumer mais personne en
Espagne n'avait encore vu de cigare on
ne savait même pas que ça existait et la
femme de Rodrigo comme tout le monde or
voilà qu'elle sort de la maison et le
trouve en train de fumer paniqué la dame
s'enfuit en hurlant dans la rue que son
mari est possédé par le démon résultat
Rodrigo des l'homme qui découvrit le
cigare dans le Nouveau Monde fut
condamné à 2 ans de prison par
l'Inquisition espagnole pour avoir été
possédé par le démon avoir fait jaillir
de la fumé de sa bouche et des
étincelles de ses
yeux mais bien vite les craintes se
dissipèrent et les plantations se
développèrent à Cuba sous la tutelle de
la Couronne espagnole qui jusqu'au 19e
siècle achetaiit leur récolte aux
immigrants devenus planteurs pour
importer et traiter les feuilles en
Espagne les principales régions
tabacoles de lîle sont les provinces
d'orienteé de remédios du parti d'eau
autour de La Havane de la semielta et
enfin à l'extrême ouest de la Velta
abaro qui entoure la bourgade de pinard
Del
Rio divisé en zone ou Vega la Velta
abaro est considérée comme la MEC du
cigare car dans ces petites vallées
riantes par ceé de schoir appelés casade
de Tabacco poussent les tabacs qui ont
fait la renommée mondiale du havan
chacune d'elles de par son sol et son
exposition produit des crues de saveurs
différentes les plus délicats étant issu
des Vegas sint Louis et s rine y
Martinez dont l'antique plantation oyo
de monteré de rossé renire donna son nom
à l'une des plus grandes marques de
cigares mis à part quelques coopératives
étatiqu les planteurs ou vegeros sont
propriétaires de petites plantation de 2
à 5 hectares rassemblé autour des
villages qui vivent au rythme du tabac
une adition prés à cette cure
incompatible avec la grande
extension notre famille a toujours été
dans la production du tabac de cigar non
seulement mon père mais aussi mes
grandsparents nous avons toujours essayé
de luer la plantation au plus passionné
de la famille parce que cette culture
est une culture
familiale une plantation de tabac c'est
comme un jardin cela exige une attention
quotidienne aujourd'hui bien que je ne
sois pas très vieux je n'ai que 48 ans
je sais qu'un demifs me
succédera parce que le problème c'est
qu'onend pas en un
[Musique]
an il faut consacrer à la plantation une
partie de sa vie pour pouvoir dire qu'on
a appris quelque chose car au fond nous
ne savons jamais rien du
tabac le tabac est ici une plante
d'hiver le calendrier du planteur
commence pendant la première quinzaine
d'août avec la préparation des
sols sous le climat tropical les
températures avoisinent les 40 degr et
le travail seit l'au c'est l'époque des
labours certains paysans comme Alejandro
Robaina le plus important vegero de sint
Louis que le quotidien national grandma
désigna comme le meilleur planteur du
monde ont leur secret lui ne retourne
jamais la terre il se contente de
l'apanir pour la laisser reposer
jusqu'au
semail on se retrouve pas ça
on a beaucoup de problèmes avec les
semences parce que comme on SME en
septembre à une époque encore ass
plusvieuse on en perd beaucoup ce qui
peut briser le rythme des
semills si bien qu'on est obligé de
replanter de ou TR fois on prend du
retard ça s'accumule et au final au
moment de la récolte on ntient pas
toujours la qualité de feuille
souhaité
les graines de tabac étudié et
sélectionné par les techniciens des
centres de recherche sont fournis au
planteur par les représentants de la
Cuba tabaco réparti dans toute la voelta
aujourd'hui pour Pier les pertes
occasionné par les semails en pleine
terre la station expérimentale développe
le système des miniotes qui consiste à
faire pousser les plantules à l'abri sur
des substrats de sable de pelures de riz
et de terreau
ce système offre de nombreux
avantages il améliore le rendement
jusqu'à obtenir 900 plans au m
car la qualité de la posture est
également meilleure avec des racines
plus vigoureus et les plans sont plus
résistants au maladies de toutes
S
les maladies les orages ou le vent du
sud qui flétrit les feuilles sont de
redoutables adversaires pour les
planteurs de tabac de cigares mais le
principal ennemi sont les insectes parmi
lesquels la virulante fourmie bibiragua
qui dévore les bourgeons ou ronge les
feuilles le vegero passe une grande part
de son temps à leur élimination repiqué
dans les champs à la mi-octobre puis
buté afin de favoriser leur irrigation
et leur croissance les jeunes plant
atteindront leur maturité vers la fin
décembre pour les vegeros producteurs de
cap ces feuilles de tabac qui forment
l'enveloppe externe du cigare et font sa
beauté l'obtention de feuilles de
qualité parfaite sans trous ni taches
impose de protéger les plantations de
l'ardeur du soleil ce sont les tapados
ces Baines de mousseline monté sur des
piquets qui furent introduits en 1903
concentrés dans les Vegas de SaintLouis
et de San ran les plantations sous
tapados en neigent le paysage tropical
ainsi protégé ce tabac est appelé
Tabacco tapado et distingué du Tabacco
de sol cultivé en plein air de moins bel
aspect qui composera la tripe du cigare
l'intérieur la plante de tabac se divise
grosso modo en trois parties la corona
le Centro et le libre de pied la corona
est la partie supérieure de la plante la
plus proche du Soleil le cent est la
partie intermédiaire et le libre de pied
la partie inférieure si on regarde le
schéma d'un plan de tabac on se rend
compte que les feuilles centros sont les
plus grandes feuilles celles qui ont la
meilleure qualité et la meilleure
texture les coronases qui sont des
feuilles naissantes montant à la
recherche du soleil sont donc plus
petites quoique d'une texture plus douce
plus
délicate enfin les libre de pied qui
sont les plus proches de la terre sont
d'une qualité moindre à la fois par leur
beauté et leur
taille pour favoriser le développement
maximum de la foliation on procède
régulièrement au déboutonnage qui
consiste à détacher les bourgeons qui se
cach sous les grandes feuilles et
affaibliss la
plante COS loes Haen
ahíendo
esperan in
[Musique]
Azul
Amane début janvier tous les villages de
la Velta se mobilisent pour commencer la
récolte qui dure de 60 à 80 jours et
s'effectue par palier successif les
feuilles du libre de pied qui arrivent
les premières à maturité sont cuilllies
d'abord suivies par les saintos et enfin
les
[Musique]
Coronas l'époque de la récolte fait la
joie des planteurs de tabac de
cigar depuis toujours à Cuba c'est un
prétexte à faire la
fête c'est aussi le moment où le
planteur a le plus de
travail o il doit redoubler
d'attention le vrai motif de la fête
c'est qu'à ce momentl le planteur se
réalise
pleinement
[Musique]
normale
sous la tutelle du vegero qui possède
généralement sa ou ses propres casas de
tabaco la récolte va suivre son premier
traitement le séchage qui dure en
moyenne 40 jours cousu deux par deux
généralement par des femmes appelées
artadoras les feuilles sont suspendues à
de longue perche d'un bois soigneusement
apprêté pour ne pas imprégner le tabac
de son odeur on dit que le tabac est mis
à la pente pour indiquer cette période
de séchage sous le toit pentu des
casas entre paysans on dit toujours
qu'on est plus planteur dans la cassa de
tabaco que dans le champ parce que le
séchage est une des étapes les plus
importante pour le
tabac un tabac qui sèche trop vite par
exemple il fait un temps du Nord froid
et sec il sèche en prenant une couleur
verte or en ce moment sur le marché
mondial ils nous disent que ce n'est pas
la qualité qu'ils veulent nous il faut
qu'on obtienne un tabac moiré un peu
rose on doit donc jouer avec le climat
fermer les Cassas de Tabacco ajuster les
perches sur lesquelles sont accrochées
les feuilles et quand il fait sec comme
aujourd'hui ouvrir les Cassas pendant la
nuit afin que l'humidité rentre et que
le tabac prenne une couleur
franciscoan ver de San raconte même
qu'il lui arrive par mauvais temps
d'installer son lit au milieu du tabac
pour mieux surveilleres précieuses
feuilles de
cap pour que nous soyons satisfaits il
faut que la feuille a toutes ses
qualités cette
longueur cette largeur est qu'elle soit
douce comme
celleille
dans laquelle on peut rouler de cigares
bon pour l'exportation et de pour la
consommation
nationale je dis pour la consommation
nationale parce qu'ici près de la veine
principale cette veine est un peu trop
épaisse et elle sera visible elle
marquera le
cigare alors que là sur le bord les
veines sont quasi
imperceptibles
le paysan roule souvent son cigare sur
sa cuisse comme je le fais là et il est
parfait c'est quelque chose de très
naturel pour nous de se rouler un cigare
de cette façon et ça donne un des
meilleurs cigares du
monde le paysan fait ça tous les jours
et ça donne un CIG aussi réulier
cylindri que celui qui sort de la
fabrique maintenant j'aurais besoin
d'une allumette mais on en trouve pas en
ce
moment un matin à l'aube quand
l'humidité ambiante est assz forte pour
ne pas risquer défriter le tabac en le
manipulant les feuilles séchées sont
décrochées rassemblé en bouquet appelés
matoule et envoyé dans un descentre de
tri les escordas qui jalonnent la Velta
à Barau selon qu'ell fourniront des
capes des sous-capes la première peau du
cigare ou la tripe les feuilles de tabac
ne suivront pas le même
traitement la production de chaque
planteur est soigneusement identif
éblir son rglement par la Cuba Tabacco
qui centralise la récolte de
Cuba avant de passer à la sélection les
feuilles sont humidifié pour pouvoir
être manipulé c'est le qui se répter
selon des méthodes différentes avant
chaque manipulation tout au long du
processus qui mène au
cigar
les matoules ouvertes les feuilles vont
alimenter au fur et à mesure l'atelier
de sélection où différents triis vont se
succéder les plus poussé étant réservé
aux feuilles de
cap le savoir des paysanes qui dans
toute la Velta effectuent cette R est
l'héritage de la tradition du tabac car
s'il faut reconnaître d'un coup d'œil
avec exactitude les différences de
longueur et de largeur des feuilles
toutes leurs Nuan de couleur ainsi que
leurs imperfections il faut aussi juger
au toucher de l'aspect charnu de la
feuille qui permet d'évaluer sa
combustibilité ainsi que sa force les
différentes classes de force du tabac
qu'on appelle les tiempos les temps sont
du plus faible au plus puissant le
volado le SEO et le ligero qui joueront
un rôle très important dans la
composition du mélange qui fera le goût
du
cigare
on les différencie très bien les
feuilles c'est comme si on parlait d'une
personne de couleur une blanche une
blonde une brune avec les yeux bleus
imaginez il y a 40 et quelques classes
de feuilles prenons le ligero il y a qu
classes de
ligero classes de Pado et C et ce on les
sélectionne par ta par texture par
couleur et à la fin cela fait 40 et
quelques
classes à proximité de l'escorida se
trouve généralement le DESP qui est
l'atelier
d'écotage ici sontcé et sélectionné les
feuilles destinées à l'intérieur du
cigare ou cell qui serviront pour la
sousape cette première pe dans laquelle
est la tripe l'écotage vise à supprimer
la partie la plus épaisse de la nervure
centrale qui se consume mal et n'a pas
très bon goût elle est arrachée au moyen
d'un ongle de métal effilé sur une
longueur qui dépend de l'utilisation
ultérieure de ce
tabac les tabacs de tripe sont
généralement écotés jusqu'à la moitié de
la feuille
tandis que les feuilles destinées au
souscap le sont seulement jusqu'à la 3è
ou la 4è veine comme on le dit dans le
langage du laavane les veines désignant
les petites nervures
adjacentes la culture du tabac est une
affaire très compliquée elle exige
beaucoup d'attention pendant
l'élaboration tout le
temps c'est comme une femme il faut en
prendre soin la
caresser le tabac c'est pareil il faut
le manipuler le frôler et puis bien le
regarder
pour savoir si la prochaine récolte sera
bonne le paysan prend une feuille de
tabac avant le séchage et l'enroule de
cette manière sur son cigare ainsi celui
qui connaît sa plantation se rend à peu
près compte de la qualité qu'URA sa
récolte de tabac l'écotage terminé vient
le moment de la fermentation durant 30 à
60 jours selon leur niveau de force les
feuilles montées en tas appelées pilon
vont perdre les dérivéses azoté qui les
composent il faut surveiller
régulièrement la température afin
d'éviter que le tabac ne se mette à
brûler ensuite par petit paquet elles
iront reposer et sécher très lentement
sur les pariasses ces immenses étagères
ajourées généralement situé dans les
combles des
[Musique]
bâtiment
cette année la récolte sera bonne
regarde comme il brûle bien quand le
tabac est vert il ne brûle pas comme ça
mais cette récolte va être bonne quand
elle sera sèche elle sera encore
meilleur c'est en séchant que le tabac
devient vraiment
bon
la fermentation des feuilles de cap se
fait à part et bien souvent dans les
fabriques de La Havane où elles vont
être transporté dans des condition toute
particulière pour ne pas risquer de les
abîmer d'abord rassemblé en gavillas
bouquet de 40 feuilles d'une même classe
elles vont être réunies en manoc de qure
gavill pour être ensuite emballé dans un
Tero qui est un emballage cubique en
jagua l'cce Palm cubain qui a la
propriété de conserver
a d'assurer le maintien de la qualité
des CAP durant leur
[Musique]
voyage
d
paeteam
Rico Dale d Dale d Dale d te Dale d
[Musique]
D
le voyage jusqu'à La Havane toutes ces
feuilles qui ont subi leur première
métamorphose doivent l'effectuer pour
devenir cigar et s'en aller un jour en
fumé vers le ciel du havan rejoindre
peut-être ces esprits que les Indiens
convoquai grâce à elle et qu'aujourd'hui
encore les cultes de possession
afroubain attir dans leur
Volut
cielo avanado la Madre de Dios cantemos
el a a su
Concepción padre nuestro que estás en
los cielos santificado sea tu nombre
Venga nosros tu reino
i
nuro j'appelle ma mère et elle ne
m'entend
pas j'appelle mon père et lui non plus
mais j'appelle mes esprits qui viendront
peu à
[Musique]
peu bueno en el nombre del padre del
hijo y del espíritu Santo hay cosas que
yo realmente cuando que no he podido
resolver y poniéndole a a la Comisión de
Santa Teresita del niño de Jesús Santa
Teresa Niño de Santa Teresa a remar a
remar a
remar AR remar a remar a remar a remar
remar marinero la Virgen de regla nos va
acompañar
un
desvimice
otro yo ns que
[Musique]
victoriaer
Partagas la corona hupman
ellagito questestaré
redelmundo arrivés dans ces grandes
manufactures de La Havane les tabacs de
cap vont subir la préparation nécessaire
à leur manipulation et au roulage des
cigares les manoes sont défaites et à
nouveau les feuilles sont soigneusement
déplié une à une avant d'être
[Musique]
humidifié
dans chaque fabrique deux ateliers
d'escorida et de despalio traitent les
feuilles de cap issu des premiers tris
effectués près des
plantations la sélection se fait
directement en fonction des besoins de
la manufacture et des modèles ou format
de cigares qu'elle produit ces modèles
que les amateurs appellent souvent
modules et que les ouvrier du tabac les
tabacs Kéros appellent
Vitol ainsi chaque feuille suivant sa
taille permettra de caper tel ou telelle
Vitol dont les noms comme Mareva
Carolina prominente ne sont pas ceux
qu'utilisent les
[Musique]
amateurs
le moment crucial de la préparation des
tabacs qui vont composer le cigare est
celui du pesage où sont établis les
mélanges ou Lig qui lui donneront sa
force et son
goût dans l'industrie tabacole les noms
des différents types de feuilles qui
composent la Liga sont volado SEO et
ligero
ce sont elles qui donnent au cigar une
bonne combustion une saveur déterminée
et des caractéristiques particulières
les proportions et l'origine de chacune
de ces feuilles sont gardé secrètes
c'est le grand mystère que chaque
fabricant emporte dans la tombe ou
transmet à son successeur lorsqu'il
quitte la
[Musique]
fabrique
la galère est l'atelier des rouleurs de
cigares les Torcé d'or la galère est un
théâtre aime à dire les vieux torcédor
un théâtre populaire bruyant où les
acteurs sont des visages et des mains
qui dansent et où se joue à chaque
instant la naissance d'un bon
pour pour exécuter un cigare le Torcé
d'or qui a disposer sur son établi les
différentes feuilles du mélange commence
par étaler sur sa planche après un
ultime écotage les demi-feuilles qui
constituent la
sououscape puis il rassemble des
feuilles de volado SEO et ligero qui
vont former la tripe du cigare en
évaluant leurs proportion ainsi que
l'homogénéité du cylindre à
créé alors il les roule dans la souscape
pour former ce qu'on appelle la
poupée
cette poupée dont un coup de chavette la
lame inséparable du Torcé d'or marque la
tête avant qu'elle n'aille reposer dans
le moule bloc où elle prendra sa forme
parfaitement
[Musique]
cylindrique
une fois plein le moulebloc est mis sous
presse où il va rester entre 20 minutes
et une demi-heure le temps pour un
torset d'or d'en charger plusieurs
[Musique]
autres ce métier qui exige l'intuition
du cuisinier et la dextérité du
prestigitateur se transmettait de pè en
fils on apprenait dans l'atelier
familial ou dans la cuisine les secrets
de cet
[Musique]
artisanat j'ai commencé parce que mon
frère et trois amis à lui avaient monté
une espèce d'atelier de fabrication de
cigares il travaillait de nuit de 8 à 11
quand le travail commençait il faisait
des cigares
j'avais entre 12 et 13 ans et j'allais
avec eux c'est comme ça que j'ai appris
les métiers de la fabrique écter la
feuille de cap mettre la
bague tout ça je l'ai appris petit à
petit et j'ai aussi appris à faire mes
cigares
[Musique]
aujourd'hui chaque fabrique dispose
d'une école dans un coin de la galère où
les postulant torcéor le
classe l'apprentissage dure 9 mois mais
si l'élève est doué et atteint le niveau
d'un bon rouleur de cigar en moins de
temps on évalue en
conséquence c'est le professeur qui
décide le temps que doit prendre
l'apprentissage
[Musique]
au sortir de la presse la poupée est
roulée dans une demifeuille du plus bel
aspect la
cape la finition de la tête du cigare
qui est la partie que le fumeur met en
bouche exige de savantes découpes et un
soin tout particulier
elle donne sa perfection virginale au
cigares et quand elle sera ouverte et
mise en bouche par l'amateur elle doit
pouvoir résister aux
morsures une colle végétale dénué de
goût lui assure sa
tenue
[Musique]
enfin une pastille de tabac à posé comme
un point d'exclamation vient condamner
le cigare à la coupe nette de son
pied le poids et l'épaisseur de la
vitole parce qu'il faut la passer par le
CPO vous savez ce que c'est que le
CP le CPO est une tablette avec un trou
au diamètre du cigare le cigare doit
passer dans cet anneau sans se
déchirer et le poids aussi est important
car s'il est trop lourd c'est qu'il y a
trop de feuilles de tabac et il est donc
trop serré sil est tropé
il est trop lâche et il se consume aussi
très mal ce sont les choses les plus
difficiles qui
[Musique]
soit une institution des plus étonnantes
dans les ateliers de torcédor de Cuba
est le lecteur qui deux fois par jour
fait la lecture au
[Musique]
rouleur en général la séance du matin
est consacré à la lecture du journal tis
que l'après-midi un roman comme I crédit
Triolet est parcouru jour après
jour établi à la demande des torcédor en
1866 dans la fabrique el Figaro de La
Havane la lecture permit au peuple des
fabriques de se cultiver tout en
travaillant et de développer leur
conscience sociale avec la première
association de secours mutuel
[Musique]
ouvrier
le résultat c'est qu'au fil des ans les
rouleurs de cigares sont devenus la
classe ouvrière cubaine la plus
cultivée il y a même une anecdote
étonnante au sujet d'un juge fameux de
La Havane des années 30 qui était
spécialisé dans les litiges entre
ouvriers et
patron il se trouvait en face d'une
affaire opposant un rouleur de cigar et
un patron ou une
fabrique il employait toujours cette
expression il est très difficile de
plaider contre les avocats du
Diable car c'est comme ça qu'à l'époque
on appelait les rouleurs de cigares les
avocats du
diable ce qui mérite bien quelques
applaudissements
un contrôle de qualité des havanes est
mené par sondage dans la galère mais
aussi à toutes les étapes de la mise en
boîte le classement des cigares par
couleur qui permet de présenter des
boîtes au contenu parfaitement homogène
et d'une performance d'acuité visuelle
quoique les avis divergent d'un
sélectionneur à l'autre il y aurait
environ 70 nuances de couleurs
différentes un cigare étant parfois
difficile à distinguer d'un autre les
fabricants du siècle dernier entourèrent
leur cigar d'une bague pour marquer leur
production l'histoire attribue cette
trouvaille aux commerçants de
hollandais gust block l'invention de la
lthographie permit au centaines de
fabriques qui existai à l'époque à Cuba
de produire ces bagues qui contribuèr
grandement à la renommée mondiale du
havan car très vite génér une forme de
marting en décorant les cigares à
l'effigie d'amateur célèbr de RO ou
d'hom Politi pas un club sect du monde
industriel alors en pleine expansion ne
résista à la tentation d'avoir des
havanes portant son blason aujourd'hui
au luxe ostentatoire des bagues nombre
d'amateurs préfèrent la classe sobre de
la présentation à fagou de 5 cigar
appelé demirou qu'en sert simplement un
élégant ruban de
soie les boîtes de cèdre dans lesquelles
vont reposer ou voyager les havanes sont
souvent décorés à l'extérieur et à
l'intérieur de petits tableau
cette opération s'effectue dans
l'atelier du filet à dos où les boîtes
une fois rempli sont Cellé par un filet
de papier qui empêchera les cigares de
se
dessécher on s'accorde à
penser été le premier fabricant à
employer une Vista de lux pour la
production de ces
fabriques ce n'est pas prouvé d'un point
de vue historique en tout cas aones a
été l'un des précurseurs de cette
technique et l'un de ceux qui ont créé
les vistas les plus brillantes et les
plus
luxueux il est aussi un des premiers
pour ne pas dire le premier à utiliser
le pan de Oro la dorure à la
feuille comme on voit sur une Vista de
l'époque ces médailles d'orées le son à
la feuille
d'or véritables œuvres d'art les
milliers de Vista et bagues qui
racontent à leur manière l'histoire du
pourau sont devenus objets de collection
la
vitolphilie dans le sous-sol d'un vieil
hôtel particulier de la Havane Orlando
Arteaga qui depuis les années 70 a
rassemblé toutes les pièces que les
fabriques disparues ont produit en leur
temps est à la tête d'une petite
entreprise la vitola
qui est la caverne d'Alibaba des
collectionneurs du monde
entier il y a des collectionneurs dans
énormément de
pays on peut citer par exemple l'Espagne
qui me paraît être le pays où on en
compte le plus et la France
l'Angleterre les États-Unis la Belgique
la
Hollande mais aussi le
Japon ici nous av plus 3000 bagues
différentes ce sont celles qui se
commercialisent il doit y avoir environ
300 vistas
différentes je le répète ce n'est qu'une
faible part de ce qui s'est fait à Cuba
à travers
l'histoire il y a des pièces qui se sont
vendu à 700 800
dollars et même parfois pour plus de
dollars
[Musique]
le temps est venu pour les cigares de
quitter l'atmosphère bruissante des
fabrique pour rejoindre les armoires
luxueuses des boutiques le saut de
garantie et le bandeau abanos certifie
leur pureté et la qualité de leur
fabrication à la main etcho Amano dans
quelques grandes manufactures comme
partaga ou la corona qui appartiennent à
la Cuba tabaco des boutiques proposent
au touristes des sélections de grandes
marqu cubaines généralement dans ces
officines des torcédor de démonstration
présentent aux visiteurs les secrets du
roulage ils sont l'élite des torcédor
sorties des galères grâce à leur
maîtrise absolue des mélanges et des
arômes le fin du fin pour les
inconditionnels du pourau consiste à
leur commander directement des cigares à
leur goût rodolpo taboada torsédor du la
DEL Tabacco à la corona est l'un
de j'ai de bons
clients j'ai des clients qui sont
commerçants chef de cuisine français
avocat et même des hommes politiques
espagnols de bons
[Musique]
clients
rouler le cigare est un
art un art qui de La Havane jusqu'en
Europe est aussi un art de vivre dont
les ambassadeurs comme la maison Gérard
père et fils négociant à Genève
transmettent le voluptueux
message l'amateur vraiment se fait
plaisir à à découvrir ses arômes ses
parfums ses
richesses c'est vrai que c'est rentré
aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on pourrait
appeler les la famille des produits de
bouche s'il y a 15 ans la majorité des
cigares cubains avaient une tendance et
une notoriété à des cigares puissants
riches corsés et parfois je dirais à la
limite à la limite de ce qu'on peut on
peut digérer aujourd'hui nous arrivons
avec des havanes qui sont beaucoup plus
doux des des havanes qui sont beaucoup
plus frais des havan des havanes qui
propose des arômes beaucoup plus
confortables et ça je crois que c'est un
un immense pas en
avant
la fumée du Havane est une musique dont
chaque type de cigare développe une
tonalité le petit corona ou le corona
sont deux modules qui de tout temps
vraiment ont été très très apprécié par
par je dirais une grande quantité
d'amateurs de de havane c'est un cigare
qu'on peut qu'on peut vraiment apprécier
quand on a envie c'est-à-dire au moment
d'un travail au moment d'une promenade
ou d' déjeuner léger le grand concurrent
si on peut appeler ça comme ça du petit
corona restera toujours le corona qui a
mon avis est un cigare qui aussi a les
mêmes je dirais symptômes finalement que
le petit corona mais par contre avec une
une petite tête de plus qui permet à
l'amateur de cigare de pouvoir jouir de
son avan avec un peu plus de temps et je
veux dire que c'est un module aussi très
prisé voilà peut-être les les deux
seules tailles je dirais qu'il sont
représentés vraiment dans la grande
majorité aujourd'hui des marques
cubaines qui sont le petit corona et le
corona le grand panatella c'est
l'Apollon du Havane c'est c'est tout en
en finesse c'est tout en longueur sont
des cigares qui sont très élancé qui
dans les les années 60 ont fait je
dirais le grand bonheur des amateurs de
havane ces cigares là étaient beaucoup
plus pour l'après dîner pour le soir et
accompagnait les amateurs de cigares de
l'époque pour pour leur
soirée les grands modules au format
qu'on voit comme le double corona qui
qui est quand même un module de 19 cm de
long qui est 2 cm de diamètre qui sont
des cigares qui sont parfois difficiles
à être dégusté pour plusieurs raisons
parce que parce qu'on n' pas toujours le
temps parce que ils peuvent aussi
fatiguer l'amateur tout simplement et
bien ces modules là en réalité il y a 20
ans en arrière n'étaient pratiquement et
quasi était quasi inconnu un des modules
les plus appréciés qui fait fait partie
de ces modules qui sont généreux qui
sont aussi très ouverts et bien je parle
du robusto ce cigar aux allures un tout
petit peu je dirais de petit jouflu et
qui sont en général qui sont en général
appréciés par les amateurs qui aiment à
l'image de celui-ci qui aiment les
arômes les arômes doux les arômes
généreux qu'on retrouve aussi bien sûr
avec avec des arômes beaucoup plus
puissant et capiteux dans certaines
autres marques l'esprit de avan est fait
au travers de tout ça il est fait au
travers de ces module il est fait à
travers de ses goûts de ses parfums de
ses richesses de ses côtés onctueux de
ses côtés gras de ses côtés boisés de
ses côtés un peu plus puissant de ces
côtés épicés tout ça fait aussi le
jardin du
havan un jardin de l'Eden objet de tous
les désirs et de toutes les attentions
car le havan est un être vivant qu'il
faut conserver et préparer dans des
salles de maturation qui recrée
artificiellement l'ambiance humide de sa
naissance et lui permettent de s'affiner
lentement en développant ses
[Musique]
arômes chaque 60 jours nous allons le
contrôler dans les salles de maturation
pour qu'il soit arrivé à terme de cette
maturation pour le sortir on essaie de
le sortir
je dirais
avec son plus beau ramage qui va faire
de lui quand on va le présenter le
prince des
Princes l'architecture de havan se
compose en trois parties la première
partie qu'on appellera le pied la
seconde partie qu'on appellera le corps
et la trisème partie qui se prénomme la
tête ces trois parties jouent un grand
rôle un grand rôle au niveau de la
du produit pourquoi tout simplement
parce que au départ si le cigar a
tendance à commencer sur une valeur plus
douce plus éloigné plus frî plus on
rentrera dans le cors du cigare plus les
arômes de
celuiciigneront autrement dit dans le
jargon du monde du havan on appelle ça
le foin le divin et le
purin comme les v de grand
cru les
enchè
av quelle puissance mystérieuse inspire
à ceux qui t'ont rencontré cette
déraisonnable
passion pour désigner la combustion
parfaite d'une feuille de cap les
véérose de la Velta à Bar disent qu'elle
brûle
àabella
Brû à la V regarde c'est
ça comment tu connais
ça regarde comme ça se consume bien
c'est ça qu'on appelle Cuba BR à la V
quel bon tabac il brûle à la
[Musique]
v
se Baila se Baila all se Baila así por
la madug se Baila se Baila se
BA